vous avez donc voté chacun prendre une
personne trans fermerions voir partir
une personne qui pour vous n'a pas sa
place dans cette aventure
une personne
qui n'a plus sa place sur l'île bonne
nuit les médias de l'actualité de l'adar
cas
on va démarrer
avec guillaume genton
yao genton
pour qui voter vous
je suis désolé mathieu mais je te
demande de quitter l aventure
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et en réalité tu le sais c'est un cadeau
que je te fais ce qu'il ya quelques
semaines mathieu m'a confié thierry
l'esa banham ne laissait pas insensible
pour de vrai
que ça moment privilégié et fera très
plaisir à battre love me tender
on avait un agrément c'est vrai
elle a appelé dans l'après-midi pour
voter contre une autre personne
vous nous direz de qu'il s'agit tout à
l'heure fait avec plaisir merci roswell
géraldine maillet mathieu
mathieu tu me fais peur tu est le clone
de tpm paix ou la clémence si tu
préfères tu es le meilleur tu fait de
l'ombre à tout le monde tu as la
répartie et résistant le roi de la
punchline je suis sûr qu'il serait le
meilleur sur l'épreuve des poteaux donc
ça c'est sûr
[Rires]
clay trop et nous on est à la traîne
derrière je veux que tu partes c'est
trop beau donc une gas exactement
comme une autre c'était parce que c'est
pas vous inquiétez pas il parce qu'on
avait prévu parce que ça avec tous les
six mois il s'en va
question de jours c'est parce que vous
aviez prévu non parce que j'avais un
jean à la grille mais aussi avec et ce à
une stratégie les stratégies et ben ça
tu se retourner contre eux
[Applaudissements]
bernard montiel yamin stratégie vous
comprenez le jeu déjà
visiblement il y avait une stratégie
obama pas tenu au courant gérard dine a
alors pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'elle est la meilleure elle s'exprime
mieux que moi elle est brillante donc
elle est dangereuse il faut la verrue
donc vous virer géraldine ce qu'elle est
meilleure que vous oui bah virer tout
c'est la stratégie l'idée de koh lanta
avec ma roue j'aime bien le bras vous
[Rires]
pas idée
isabelle morini-bosc
n'est pas très aimé ses assistants ouais
bah oui bah oui une grande histoire
d'amour amical déçu j'ai tout fait pour
le seigneur amicalement je l'invité à
déjeuner j'ai mangé proprement sans mes
doigts sans que vous avez déjeuné
ensemble mais plusieurs foyers mais
surtout que je dis c'est payé il a pris
là j'ai pas présent traité pas pris
d'essai reims a duré seize minutes
et en plus ils mangent et d'une poussée
dehors donc j'en ai marre de d'essayer
d'être gentille et victoire par les
toits des producteurs qui étaient
intéressés mais mon 17e trou du cul je
n'y suis pour rien
des produits dont vous venez que c'est
un trou du cul oui on est surtout pas pu
dire que c'était un trou du cul par pas
fiable donc voilà toi tu apparais
amoureux qui ne cessa docu pas de ma
carrière par la maladie si si qui
étaient intéressés que touriste et
intervient nous tardait à moi de qui tu
le verras pris le
[Applaudissements]
vous avez parlé à batna à un producteur
de terrible pour lui dire quoi papoulias
c'est un comédien né puis surtout qu'il
le prenne et qu'il nous l'enlève et un
tas de l'influencé abbas et non les
projets il le sait syrie nasa veut
durable dont j'ai tant que jeunes et où
il y avait bernard qu'était moi oui
c'est vrai on avait soutenu mathieu
c'est vrai et alors pourra y avait dit
que ça m'a surtout aidé de on dit quoi
ils ont utilisé pas pour quand il y
avait un tiers temps que des jeunes et
kiabi méfiez-vous c'est un trou du cul
je
les emmerde sais pas qui c'est c'est de
là apparemment ils disent que vous êtes
un trou du cul
ils connaissent bien
fou
de talent fait peur quoi laisser les
gens à la médiocrité renchérit est
dedans mais c'est prenois c'est vrai
vraiment
il a maintenant les 400 qui pouvait
peut-être pas le truc avec moi
ça fait quatre fois que tu la mets une
et quatre albums à boire
isa à l'aube à l'aube d'une vie bien
remplie de trop d' analyse médias en
radio en télé je me disais l'envi
d'avoir envie je pense que tu n'as plus
lent vie d'avant il est dix à la
dernière fois déjà c'est exactement ça
va là encore la mémoire je suis très
cohérent comme garçons ouais voilà quoi
que je très cohérent donc un peu de
repos pour isa je suis pour qu'ils
quittent tout de suite l'aventuré
sans commandement de paiement comme mon
dieu est un succès immédiat j'ai même
pas envie qu'on finisse la table
ça déroule à nantes parlent même pas je
te regarde pas
elle tend sortait même plaire tél
sacré en parallèle ça va toi tu es pour
le dire c'est camping paradis de ce soir
sera bien super isa merci avec ses
bombes à
couiza
faut sortir isa
[Applaudissements]
belle fille isa
veulent plus alors moi j'ai mis benjamin
parce qu'il a laissé planer le doute sur
quelque chose d'éventuels qui se serait
passé et qui a failli coûter bonbon donc
coûté mon encontre en conflent et c'est
pour ça ah oui mais ça c'est sûr la
aller quand même quand même nom mais ce
que l'information
on se rendait pas compte la tranquille
voilà c'est fait et bien fait mais dites
moi c'est en fait et c'est ce truc
j'étais malade à eux seuls
abonnés
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je balance tout ce
soit bah oui
on a failli coûter votre cou mais c'est
gênant quand même sinon sexy bas si j'y
vais
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit benjamin
thomas nîmois comme la dernière chance
pisa
[Applaudissements]
jean paquette il attaquait avec mado à
gaza nous aimons il
[Applaudissements]
y aussi bien pour la star il ya pour
l'instant de mathieu de visa c'est vrai
c'est vraiment eu l'idée il ya un temps
pour tout oui il ya un temps pour vivre
après sept ans
il est atteint pour vivre et un tampon
c'est vrai c'est vrai en revanche comme
tu dirais c'est bien j'ai remarqué une
petite dérive de concernant au fil des
mois qui m'inquiète une dérive un peu
réactionnaire et aux jo ah oui
quand-même il vas y tire à balle
parfois mal donne son avis sur tout et
le droit qui me surprend mais que tu
défend avec brio et comme je disais paul
eluard pour ne citer 1 c'est mathieu la
visite d'un mirador quoi
payer c'est un mirador qui permet
d'avoir une vue panoramique sur la vie
il est temps pour toi d'avoir une vue
globale de tpm p mais depuis chez toi
[Rires]
il a bien entendu je ne suis pas
d'accord c'est moi j'appelle compagnie a
vu comme verticalement
en plus y'a plein de trucs à part la
retraite izal t
il descendre d'oeil à plat avec les
croisières paquet tu descendais des
fleuves tard en décembre
2006 a
alors ta place bien entendu ici quoi
qu'il arrive c'est ce qui a fait le
pratiquement le plus d'émissions cette
année ab oui
pour ça pour elle et qu'elle est vieille
parce qu'elle en fait beaucoup
[Rires]
valérie benaïm
et sa belle-fille
d'accord
d'à-côté toute l'équipe est d'accord
avec moi j'en ai parlé pourquoi tel film
maintenant vous a obscurci l'esprit
cyril hanouna
plus que l'ombre de vous même un fait
vrai ouais c'est vrai les vraies
vedettes des anecdotes de 20000 km vous
l'annonçait fait rien sans vous laisser
passer
elle a un avis qui est contraire aux
boys si moi j'ai un avis contraire aux
vôtres vous me dites vous dis des
bêtises benhaim petites bêtises rémois
dont elle dit une anecdote où il quelque
chose qui est contraire à vos idées vous
dites c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites
la technique quand j'ai pas vous avez vu
ce qu'il fasse une pause pour que vous
vous retrouviez vos esprits
[Applaudissements]
bizarre
vous pouvez dire qu'elle dit n'importe
quoi trouver vraiment que je suis or
n'ont jamais d'accord avec les scandales
à tous les sl fille opérer un vote à
main levée de mes camarades
le font si ce vote vous le sanctionner
ou si vous êtes d'accord avec moi qui
est d'accord avec moi mais pas sur les
anecdotes sans intérêt mais sur le fait
qu'au mois sa pige à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
delphine vous le sentez comme ça
maintenant mais je suis déçu mais mais
effectivement je tourne ça n'en vaut
vous me soutenez parce que ben vous vous
vous voulez parce que tu es belle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la jeune génération vient pas vous celle
ci s'est montrée inquiète pour
l'égalité la bonne c'est pourquoi je
soutiendrai pas du tout parce que
delphine et elle est allée elle est
moins intégré l'équipe que vous donc
j'ai essayé de l'intégrer encore plus en
l'état après vrai ou pas delphine ben
oui parce que je suis pas voler des
choix n'est pas toujours là la vie à
paris j pas nommé dans tous les petits
blancs les qui viennent bien sûr ceux
qui habitent ma part je voulais dire non
mais c'est vrai et des deux filles c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs guillaume est
d'accord avec moi bien sûr je suis pour
pas qu'on parle comme ça de meubles
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez dit elle n'est pas de paris
c'est mon sac j'ai proposé de l'héberger
regret nuit en fait il veut toujours se
mettre dans le même état raison voilà et
c'est en plus moi je suis très ami
guillaume genton comme vous le savez
voilà et si elle peut faire une passe de
guillaume des projets insensés et dieu
sait que j'en ai fait il là bas lui ça
c'est pas gagné voilà on vient d'avoir
gardé le fait des passes des tous les
buts à la clé
alors mais alors je peux vous dire je
suis à non mais vraiment ah ouais bof je
suis sont lionel messi
mais remercie d'ailleurs
merci il nous faudra leur dire quand
même ma mère je fasse des auzines quoi
oui je vous fais des passes d où des
chiens besoin non merci merci je ne
mange pas de ce pain-là merci matthieu
delormeau
moi je suis assez effaré par ce qu'il
vient de se passer parce qu'ils
s'appellent de la vieille aux phobies ça
je le tolère pas du tout de quoi isa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire c'est moi qui vais décider
vous allez voir oui
j'ai fait recours tu es présent ce sont
comme des interventions inutiles
[Rires]
mais tu as ton salut mon avis je pense
qu'il faut et un shérif à 19h30 l'heure
est grave et puisqu'on va devoir
éliminer un chroniqueur il ya une
égalité non y'a pas si tu verras
isabelle morini-bosc trois vols partent
je vais donc refaire un tour de table
mais non mou chacun devra dire entre les
devises à montmagny mathieu avec bien
sûr un argument une argumentation claire
concise
qui fera qu'une des personnes sera
éliminé et ira voir le magnifique
concert derhille prieur dans une loge
moi je suis malade et love me tender
l'ofs match où
l'homme est chaud
on va démarrer bien sûr par mathieu
le vote isa pourquoi parce que je n'aime
pas jodar
le tas d'or mais me voilà que je suis
pas fan d'elvis presley c'était déjà pas
fan du vrai alors imagine toi irene
va lire ml je veux bizarre parce que
parce que mathieu est à côté de moi etc
sinon il va me faire chier car elle voit
là bas vous demain vous chiez donc
sperme
belle à la normale chiant rexona
saturation
alors martin moi je suis
l'homme a évité la jupe blanche à aa je
sais qu'il n'aime pas le rock alors que
j'ai déjà vu il a dansé le rock action
lève la jambe remercie vous foutez de
notre gueule la vérité voici dix
assortis bas pour matt ce que j'aime
matt d'accord à la folie isa
pourquoi parce qu'il est temps et
ça finit par où il a péché parce que
c'est lui qui peut lui prendre des
princes c'est pas moi c'est ma
vie je suis mathieu babaud parce que
j'adore isa j'adore ce qu'elle dit jeu
très souvent d'accord avec elle c'est
une femme incroyablement leurs cheveux
bienveillante le contraire de matthieu
delormeau s'acquittait les fontaines
guide
[Rires]
jégo je vais demander au public de faire
traîner par terre lapsus qui s'invite à
défoncer qui sait qui tu a défendu face
aux flics à londres le 6 juin à minuit
pour
les politiques
de pinto donc oui mathieu parce que à la
télé comme en coulisses c'est le même et
il jugeait le pic
c'est pas mal avec ce n'est pas un
cactus juge et flic ne parle pas et
allez raymond
voillat la vanne la vanne est en fait il
faut maintenant revenir à l'état normal
et arrêter les conneries et redevenir
réaliste
isa
[Applaudissements]
mais
encore un fâcheux te frappe isr vous
savez pourquoi ils sont jaloux parce que
je vous mets dans toutes les émissions
et
les émissions débute
à kaloum
ce n'est pas venu c'est parce que
j'avais le mariage de son fils si c'est
toi qui as pas brûler oui parce que vous
savez j'en ai plus pour longtemps jdi
bonne
on en a encore pour moi 15 ans tous les
deux jours grande motte pour toi aller
alors qu'ils avaient nationale match et
pourquoi pour toi pour les mêmes raisons
tout à l'heure je mets désagréable
encore un serment il est odieux et s'est
même pas divin très bien dans la motié
oui moi je vote à cette heure devant la
misa non non non mais lisa cema s'est
massé mon ami donc mathieu désolé assez
parce que le choix est difficile mais il
s'agit des franchisés a bien sûr
géraldine je ne renierai pas mes
convictions au premier tour a été pour
mathieu mon deuxième sera pour isa hier
après la langue
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le
isabelle soigner mais c'est terminé we
did
plaisir pour le plaisir visa
donnez moi
un premier vote sont beaux est ce encore
plus violent que l'on tait vous avez
besoin des merrell prieur vous allez
rejoindre avec prières dont viendrait
juste après il a bien entendu été
repêché magnifique concert merci c'est
vous là vous voyez vous reconnaissez
sanaa dans le médium le premier f au
muba petrov mes chiens mais prenez le
bordel isabelle danseurs jetée sur le
lit la belle serait
l'isabelle les aventuriers ont décidé de
vous éliminer et leur sentence est
irrévocable
vous allez rejoindre une autre aventure
l'aventuré realplayer
défi nous appelle jeu mais c'est terminé
pour
isabelle alessi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
isabelle va donc rejoindre les meilleurs
pour son concert
et rilke est incroyable ouais ouais nan
là tu t'en vas y toi
aux
[Musique]
gens tendent à les laisser merci
merci lourdes hidjab en remercie on va
les laisser pour la seule à rester là
bas va faire un petit kif et reviendra
côté sera calmée
m